here's a guy right now he's a guy right
who had hair before he went to your show
what's up brandon what's up theo mckay
harper and starley out in sin city
greatness i gotta see you singing for
you beautiful girls wait until marriage
me and my wife we were virgins until we
got married
some people say heck no you have to test
drive the car
correct you can tell if you like you got
to kick the tires i've got the biggest
penis she's ever seen
kinder singing gang big
the hell is happening dad the kid knows
it came out of a big penis man the kid's
right there the kid came out of the
penis yeah you're right she knows what
dad's work
some of that stuff's always weird to me
you know people are like uh
you know if a parent showers with their
little kid or something it's like the
kid just came out of their body
you know i don't know who's weird if
they shower with their kid i mean if the
kid's
16 or 18 that gets a little strange but
if he's a toddler you got to do your
thing man
um yeah does it does it ever work out
for people i mean it worked out for them
but you don't
i mean personally i wouldn't sign up for
something if i didn't know like would
you buy a car just off the internet but
you haven't had sex so how would you
you don't have any it's you guys both
going into the adventure at the same
time yeah i know but it's like getting
tossed in a ufc fight and you've never
fought before
like i guess i'll figure it out i just
went freaking at least
30 strong seconds with you out there and
i've never fought in ufc that's fair
my adopted father was that way he didn't
have sex until until
and then what happened you guys had a
child no well then how would me
it's my adopted father oh somebody have
sex to marriage yeah
and then and then i'm i'm assuming that
first time it was just
gushers what and then and then kids came
what the uh year they're like what this
is about a year after they got married
wade didn't have sex until marriage i
i'm with sting it man
i mean i appreciate the discipline but i
don't i don't know that's so old school
though but if
here's the thing i'm seeing though is
the the the thing i'm taking out of this
deal is
if the woman's also doing it then both
of y'all are doing it oh you're
like if you decide to both pick up
tennis you're both going to get good
over time yeah you're both
volleyback a little bit yeah and you'll
also know the only thumb up your ass
yeah yeah
you also be the only person that knows
you're the only other player they know
so it's like
there's something kind of nice about it
i think you just don't have any
question mark in your head of like you
know
and here's the other thing you guys get
to know each other at least it's all
about
you know nuts and butts true that man
you guys really get to know each other
these days people are banging and doing
sex and everything
don't know each other's names yeah these
days people ejaculating on each other
won't even let them stay at their house
for the night
damn that's crazy then we give a diet
coke
after that you know yeah people well i
wouldn't even eat somebody's cooking and
i'll bust
out on them you know that's crazy what
do you think about it don't say bust out
yeah right you know that's a little
aggressive bust out
well i mean yeah i hear you yeah
you're you're bust out on somebody but
you want to ken
place look go back to jen's place you
can see him sleep under that cover
in the back so obviously he's not doing
well
look at him he's got the fan on he's way
back there under those covers no there
he is
there he is wait so who's under the
cover yeah who's under the cover chen
did they star in glee
damn like six people from glee died
right
so far on that cast yeah it's like a
crazy that has to be a little bit like
hey hey i showed uh pull up my adopted
folks i showed them let's see them oh
those are them yeah
it's a fine looking family you got there
see these people
yeah i sent it to nick he just had it up
look at that look at us
let's see this group right here huh yeah
are those other three children or any of
those children adopted also
no they're all theirs you sure the one
on the left looks adopted almost a
little bit i would say the one on the
far right looks adopted really oh yeah
no
she's just like a mom yeah it's just
like her
brand i mean you kind of have the same
smile as the mom so the whole thing
it's who i do yeah it doesn't look out
of place i do have the same smile
yeah yeah kind of yeah bro look at that
fro you still talk to them all the time
all the time yeah and who's the little
girl in the pink jacket has she been
she seems like how old are they now um
22 20 and
play the different strokes theme song
let's see if we can hear that how old it
will help with the whole vibe
how old were you in that picture that
picture uh we took that picture when i
was
i think 17 or 18. someone said i look
30.
[Laughter]
but it also you do look pretty older
[Music]
different strokes it takes different
strokes through the world
look gary coleman is cute yeah you're
riding in that caddy
[Music]
it takes
[Laughter]
it's a little pervy at the end brother
yeah a little weird was it you got a
little
a little handsy is that weird yeah a
little handy though
well i mean yeah i mean i could i
reconnected with my um
original dad yeah yeah the og yeah the
one that the og
might he might say something to you with
that wait is he a [ __ ] or blood
huh he's neither now he's recovered yeah
he's rec there you go
he had a kill to get out there didn't he
oh he went through some [ __ ]
you got to kill it again he's like an og
kill you right now you tried to kill me
the past two weeks
i got the funniest wizards i got the
funniest i'll say i'm the worst killer
of all time because everybody here is
fine
i'm a bad killer the worst killer of all
time but also the bad killer
you got to see how og he is like he's
like wait
but when your dad ran with those type of
folks was he wearing blue or red
uh i've never seen him in red so he was
wearing blue
you don't think you would be proud i'm
wearing blue
i mean i mean you're in blue too dawg
i got this hold on where's this shout
out scotland shout out ireland shout out
gypsies dude
versus everybody dog i think i just sent
it to nick
you got to see like he's like let's see
[ __ ] you text it uh the airdrop
went to the other computer
different folks different strokes he's
like oh g-o-g
oh my god maybe we should get him in the
culture corner i mean he might say some
[ __ ]
really did you get it nick yeah yeah
what what you'll see
i'd watch your i'd watch your dad fight
brendan damn yeah that's my
i think i'd have my hands full that's my
dad he's an og
that was when he i think that's when he
like first got in
that's a clear picture too so that's
good
no joke this looks like a baseball card
from 1908.
that could be anybody dude was your dad
jackie robinson
that's my daddy if you met him or did
someone just give you that picture of me
like that
that's my daddy i know it yeah i mean it
could be anybody man that could be my
daddy is that notorious
b.i.g i don't i don't know dude yeah
that does look like victorious
that's biggie maybe that's a big papa
that's years ago marshall pope
yeah marsha pope years ago dude
is that dana stubblefield
i think that's chris dolman r.i.p bro
let's get into this episode man
uh did we answer that dude's question
yeah what did he ask oh
well you know i i get why they do it i
say sting it but i get why they do it
there's some advantages because then
your relationship's not based on
physical
[ __ ] you know and seem to work out they
got a beautiful family now
yeah they got the kid right there they
got the lady they got a kitchen
y'all say it has a big dick yeah that
guy's excited about his dick
years ago that see that kid years ago
now that's not
that's my dad it could be now that angle
of years ago go to the other years ago
picture go right down
but no back where you were this one
uh uh god that's just go back where you
were if you don't mind nate
that was the funniest clip i've ever
seen in my life oh yeah still hands down
one of the things we're right here okay
now go down
look at the on the large picture go
under the large picture right there
no right right there that one that was
the hardest i've ever left now let's see
this
now this is getting a little closer yeah
pretty similar so does marshall put my
dad
years ago yeah we got to figure this out
he could be all of our dad dude
years ago he let him go you never know
what marshall
brennan's a [ __ ] dude anything could
happen man
uh i think i i say man i think it's
probably a nice idea
i'm too i can't do it anymore i already
i had sex when i was young and yeah
when i was older damn so i'm out the
discipline how old were you
i don't know i feel like you were one of
those kids who did it young
i feel like you're one of those kids
that got molested by the babysitter
that was every kid not me bro really
no my babysitter want nothing to do with
me dude first of all if you
there's no way you can look like you
look right now
dressed in that and say i didn't get
molested by the babysitter
didn't dude seems very
[Music]
is